i'm i'm curious do you have any like
convention horror stories
because we have i know yeah we have like
we have a lot so
no one ever like tried like step the
boundary ever do anything creepy to you
at a convention
only at a doubt like which i don't go
anywhere this is actually i wanted to
talk about because when i
was you know on youtube searching clips
they were a lot from adult cons
and people seem like overly like touchy
at adult cons and they're like it's okay
yeah yeah yeah and they're people just
like you know they go up to you and
immediately like put their arm around
you i hate it when people do that to me
what are you doing i don't know please
don't touch me yeah yeah and and like it
was just kind of
odd seeing that and then people were
like yeah make out with each other
and it's like yeah yeah yeah like
how is the like difference between like
is is does the is the adult con
basically as bad as it looks
it is um uh first of all like
in japan like all those events like you
can't even touch
an idol or like a tarrant like maybe a
handshake that's why we have handshaking
events
yeah but hound is the only area you get
to feed her
i'm never watching this here that's
where that's come from yeah
you're not even like we are not
westerners so like you're not even
supposed to like
put a hand on your shoulder or not even
on her hip
yeah i guess in the west i'm okay like
you know it's for taking photos together
some people are very
gentle when i try to like do ear hands
i was just like i was like internally
dying watching some of these clips so
people just go up to you and start like
touching
if someone did that to me i'd be like i
feel like this man's catching something
yeah just smack him yeah yeah it's weird
that for some reason just because it's
an adult
convention that they can just you know
do what they want right you know they
try to grab you like on
easier chest area back area like really
yeah i know
and [ __ ] do they ever get into trouble
with it or anything like that or
ah you have to just like act like
nothing happens and you know
sometimes i just tell someone like you
know that guy just touched me and some
people like
ask nicely like is it okay i touch your
breath again
[Music]
you asked but no but then they just
try to be persistent the problem is
right is that they've they've calculated
that it's a bit rude to just do it but
they haven't quite done the rest they're
like i
probably should shouldn't have actually
actually offered
excuses excuse me excuse me milady would
you would it be
okay if i obtained a logic of like a
child being like if i say
please then maybe i can get the cookie
so some people are persistent and they
won't take no answer they offer
a tip like how much do i need to pay
like at the tip and i just said it's
like real life only
some actresses in the west like they
take tips and they
that but i was like i don't have a couch
from tipping so like yeah yeah yeah